so I wanted to make a video about GPT -
because it's been in the news recently
this very powerful language model from
open AI and I thought it would make
sense to start by just doing a video
about transformers and language models
in general because GPT 2 is a very large
language model implemented as a
transformer but you have a previous
video about generating YouTube comments
which is the same kind of task right
that's a language modeling task from
language processing to generate new
samples for cooling of the most complex
or magnetic consistent brackets like a
computer to expect found in creating
organizations
I believe that video was made October
2017 and this paper came out December
2017 which has kind of revolutionized
the way that people carry out that kind
of task that's not the GPT - that's
something before that right that's the
transformer which is a new realm
yeah relatively new architecture for
neuron networks that can do actually all
kinds of tasks but they're especially
good at this kind of language modeling
to ask
a language model is a probability
distribution over like sequences of
tokens or symbols or words or whatever
in a language so for any given like
sequence of tokens it can tell you how
likely that is so if you have a good
language model of English it can look at
a sequence of you know words or
characters or whatever and say how
likely that is to occur in English how
likely that is to be an English phrase
or sentence or whatever and when you
have that you can use that for a lot of
different tasks so if you want to
generate text then you can you can just
sort of sample from that distribution
and keep giving it its own output so you
you sample a word and then you say and
to be clear sampling from a distribution
means you're just taking your you're
sort of rolling the dice on that
probability distribution and taking
whichever one comes out so so you can
like sample a word and then and then say
okay conditioning on that given that the
first word of this sentence is V what
does the probability distribution look
like for the second word and then you
sample from that distribution and then
it's you know with a cat and you say
given that it's the cat what's likely to
come next and so on so you can you can
build up a string of text by sampling
from your distribution that's one of the
things you could use it for most of us
kind of have an example of this sort of
in our pockets of its actual absolutely
right and that's like that's the that's
the way that most people interact with a
language model I guess this is how I
often start a sentence apparently with I
I am not sure if you have any questions
or concerns please visit the plugin
settings so I can do it for the first
time in the future of that's no good
here's a different option let's just see
what this way maybe the same I am in the
morning but I can't find it on the phone
screen from the phone screen on the
phone screen on the phone screen on the
phone screen
on the phone screen I don't actually
know how this is implemented it might be
a neural network but my guess is that
it's some kind of like Markov model
Markov chain type setup where you just
for each word in your language you look
at your data set and you see how often a
particular how often each other word is
following that word and then that's how
you build your distribution so like for
the word I the most common word to
follow that is a ham and there are a few
others you know so this is like a very
simple model and this sentence on the
phone screen on the phone screen on the
phone screen he's actually very unlikely
right this is the super low probability
sentence where I would somebody type
this and the thing is it's like myopic
it's only I'm not sure I even it's
probably only looking at the previous
word it might be looking at like the
previous two words but the problem is to
look back it becomes extremely expensive
computationally expensive right
like you've got I don't know 50,000
words that you might be looking at and
so then it so you're you're you're
remembering 50,000 probability
distributions or 50,000 top three words
but you know then if you want to do 2050
thousand squared right and if you want
to go back three words you have to cube
it so you like raising it to the power
of the number of words back you want to
go which is which means that this type
of model basically doesn't look back by
the time we're saying on the it's
already forgotten
the previous time it said on the it
doesn't realize that it's repeating
itself
and there are slightly better things you
can do in this general area but like
fundamentally if you don't remember
you're not going to be able to make good
sentences if you can't remember the
beginning of the sentence by the time
you're at the end of it right and so one
of the big areas of progress in language
models is handling long term
dependencies
I mean handling dependencies of any kind
but especially long term dependencies
you've got a sentence that's like Shawn
came to the hack space to record a video
and I talked to blank right in that
situation if your model is good you're
expecting like a pronoun probably so
it's it's
she they you know them whatever and but
the relevant piece of information is the
words short which is like all the way at
the beginning of the sentence so your
model needs to be able to say oh okay
you know Shawn that's usually associated
with male pronouns so we'll put the male
pronoun in there and if your model
doesn't have that ability to look back
or to just remember what it's just said
then you end up with these sentences
that like go nowhere it's just a slight
like it might make a guess just a random
guess at a pronoun and might get it
wrong or it might just and I talked to
and then just be like Frank you know
just like introduced a new name because
it's guessing at what's likely to come
there and it's completely forgotten that
sure was ever like a thing so yeah these
kind of dependencies are a big issue
with things that you would want to
language model to do but we've only so
far talked about language models for
generating text in this way but you can
also use them for all kinds of different
things so like people use language
models for translation obviously you
have some input sequence that's like in
English and you want to output a
sequence in French or something like
that having a good language model is
really important so that you end up with
something that makes sense summarization
is a task that people often want where
you read in a long piece of text and
then you generate a short piece of text
that's like a summary of that that's the
kind of thing that you would use a
language model for or reading a piece of
text and then answering questions about
that text or if you want to write like a
chatbot that's going to converse with
people having a language model as good
like basically almost all like natural
language processing right is it's useful
to have this the other thing is you can
use it to enhance enhance a lot of other
language related tasks so if you're
doing like speech recognition then
having a good language model like
there's a lot of things people can say
that sound very similar and to get the
right one you need to be like oh well
this actually makes sense you know this
word that sounds very similar would be
incoherent in this sentence it's a very
low probability it's much more likely
that they
this thing which is like would flow in
the language and human beings do this
all the time
same thing with recognizing text from
images you know you've got two words
that look similar or there's some
ambiguity or whatever and to resolve
that you need an understanding of what
word would make sense there what word
would fit if you're trying to use a
neural network to do the kind of thing
we were talking about before of having a
phone you know autocorrect based on the
previous word or two suppose you've got
a sequence of two words going in
you've got so and then I and you put
both of these into your network and it
will then output
you know like said for example as like a
sensible next word and then what you do
is you throw away or so and you then
bring your set around and you make a new
sequence which is I said and then put
that into your network and it will put
out like I said - for example would make
sense and so on and you keep going
around but the problem is this length is
really short you try and make this long
enough to contain an entire sentence
just an ordinary length sentence and
this problem starts to become really
really hard and networks have a hard
time learning it and you don't get very
good performance and even then you're
still like have this absolute hard limit
on how long a thing you you have to just
pick a number that's like how far back
am I looking a better thing to do you
say recurring you're on network where
you you give the thing let's like divide
that up so in this case then you have a
network you give it this vector you just
like have a bunch of numbers which is
gonna be like the memory for that
network is the idea like the problem is
it's forgotten in the beginning of the
sentence by the time it gets to the end
so we've got to give it some way of
remembering and rather than feeding it
the entire sentence every time you give
it this vector and you give it to just
one word at a time of your inputs and
this vector which you initialize I guess
with zeros I want to be clear this is
not something that I've studied in a
huge amount of detail I'm just like
giving the overall like structure of the
thing but the point is you give it this
vector and the word and it outputs its
guess for the next word and also a
modified version of that vector that you
then for the next thing you give it
where did it spit out or the sequence
that it spit out and its own modified
version of the vector every cycle that
goes around it's modifying this memory
once this system is like trained very
well if you give it if you give it the
first word Shawn then part of this
vector is going to contain some
information that's like this subject of
this sentence is the word short and some
other part will probably keep track of
like we expect to use a male pronoun for
this sentence and that kind of thing so
you take this and give it to that and
these are just two instances of the same
network and then it keeps going every
time so it spits out like this is I so
then the AI also comes around to here
you might then put outside and so on but
it's got this continuous thread of of
memory effectively going through because
it keeps passing the thing through in
principle if it figures out something
important at the beginning of you know
the complete works of Shakespeare that
it's generating there's nothing strictly
speaking stopping that from persisting
from being passed through from from
iteration to iteration to iteration
every time in practice it doesn't work
that way because in practice the whole
thing is being messed with by the
network on every step and so in in the
training process it's going to learn
that it performs best when it leaves
most of it alone and it doesn't just
randomly change the whole thing but by
the time you're on the fiftieth word of
your sentence whatever the network
decided to do on the first word of the
sentence is a photocopy of a photocopy
of a photocopy of a photocopy and so
things have a tendency to fade out to
nothing it has to be successfully
remembered at every step of this process
and if at any point it gets overwritten
with something else or just it did its
best to remember it but it's actually
remembering 99% of it each time point
nine nine to the fifty is like actually
not that big of a number so these things
work pretty well but they still get the
performance like really quickly drops
off once the sentences start to get long
so this is a recurrent neural network
rnl because all of these boxes are
really the same box
because this is the same network at
different time steps it's really a loop
like this you're giving the output of
the network back as input every time so
this works better and then people have
tried all kinds of interesting things
things like LS TMS there's all kinds of
variants on this general like recurrent
Network LS TM is the thing that might
use isn't it right right
long short-term memory which is kind of
surreal but yeah so the idea of that is
it's a lot more complicated inside these
networks there's actually kind of sub
networks that make specific decisions
about gating things so rather than
having to have this system learn that it
ought to pass most things on it's sort
of more in the architecture that passes
most things on and then there's a
there's a sub there's like part of the
learning is deciding what to forget at
each step and like deciding what to
change and what to put it in what parcel
and so on and they perform better they
can hang on to the information the
relevant information for longer but the
other thing that people often build into
these kinds of systems is something
called attention which is actually a
pretty good metaphor where in the same
way that you would have networks that
decide which parts of your hidden state
to hang on to or which starts to forget
or those kinds of decisions like gating
and stuff you have a system which is
deciding which parts of the input to pay
attention to which parts to use in the
in the calculation and which parts to
ignore and this turns out to be actually
very powerful so there was this paper
when was this 2000 2017 yeah so this is
funny because this came out the same
year as the video you have about
generating YouTube comments this is in
December I think that video was October
ancient history now alright we're
talking two years ago the idea of this
is as its called attention is all you
need they developed this system whereby
it's actually as it's a lot simpler as a
as a network you can see on the diagram
here if you compare this to the diagram
for an LS TM or any of those kind of
variants it's relatively simple and it's
just kind of using attention to do
everything so when
made that video the ASTM type stuff was
like state-of-the-art and that was until
a couple of months later I guess when
this paper came out the idea of this is
that attention is all you need of it
like this stuff about having gates for
forgetting things and all of that all of
that kind of stuff in fact your whole
recurrence like architecture you can do
away with it and just use attention
attention is powerful enough to do
everything that you need at its base
attention is about actively deciding in
the same way that the LS TM is actively
deciding what to forget and so on this
is deciding which parts of some other
part of the data it's going to take into
account which parts it's going to look
at like it can be very dangerous in AI
to use words for things that are words
that people already use for the way that
humans do things it makes it very easy
transform for more finds and just make
you know get confused because the
abstraction doesn't quite work but I
think attention is a pretty decent thing
because it is it does make sense it sort
of draws the relationships between
things so you can have attention from
the output to the input which is what
that would be you can also have
attention from the output to other parts
of the output so for example when I'm
generating in that sentence like Shawn
came to record a video or whatever by
the time I get to generating the word
him I don't need to be thinking about
the entire sentence I can just focus my
attention on where I remember the name
was so the attention goes to Shawn and
then I can make the decision for to use
the word him based on that so so rather
than having to hang on to a huge amount
of memory you can just selectively look
at the things that are actually relevant
and the system learns where to look
where to pay attention to and that's
really cool like you can do it there's
attention based systems for all kinds of
things like not just text you can do
like suppose you have your input is like
an image and you want to caption it you
can actually look at when it was
outputting the secret
you can say when you generated the word
dog what was your you can get like an
attention heat map and it will highlight
the dog because that's the part of the
image that it was paying attention to
when it generated that output it makes
your system more interpretable because
you can see what it was thinking and
sometimes you can catch problems that
way as well which is kind of fun like it
generates the output that's like a man
is lifting a dumbbell or something like
that and you look at it and it's not
actually correct it's like its owner
trots and I go he's drinking some tea
out of a mug right and what you find is
then when you look at your outputs where
it says dumbbell you look at the
attention and the attention is like
mostly looking at the arms that's
usually somebody muscular who's lifting
the dumbbell in your photos it's and so
it it's overriding the fact that this
kind of looks like a mug because it was
looking at the arms so the idea is this
system which is called a transformer is
a type of neural network which just
relies very heavily on attention to
produce like state-of-the-art
performance and if you train them on a
large corpus of natural language they
can learn they can learn to do very well
right they give you they can be very
powerful language models we had the
example of a language model on your
phone that's like a very very basic and
then trying to do this with neural
networks and the problems with
remembering and so you have like
recurrent systems that keep track of
they allow you to pass memory along so
that you can remember the beginning of
the sentence at least by the end of it
and things like LS TMS there is all
these different varieties that people
try different things that are better and
hanging on to memory so that they can do
better it they can have longer term
dependencies which allows you to have
more coherent outputs in just generally
better performance and then the
transformer is is a variant on that well
is a different way of doing things where
you really focus on attention and so
these are actually not recurrent which
is an important distinction to make we
don't have this thing of like taking the
output and feeding that back as the
input and so on every time because we
have attention we don't need to keep a
big memory
that we run through every time when the
system wants to know something it can
use its attention to look back to that
part it's not like memorizing the text
as it goes it's paying attention to
different bits of the text as they as it
thinks that they're relevant to the bit
that it's looking at now and the thing
about that is when you have this
recurrent thing it's kind of inherently
serial most of the calculations for this
you can't do them until you have the
inputs and the inputs are the output of
the previous network and so you can't do
the thing that people like to do now
which is run it on a million computers
and get lightning-fast performance
because you have to go through them in
order right it's like inherently serial
where as transformers are much more
parallelizable which means you get
better computational performance out of
them as well which is another selling
point so they they work better and they
run faster so they're they're really a
step up so transformers are this really
powerful architecture they seem to give
really good performance on this kind of
sort of language modeling type tasks and
we but what we didn't know really was
how far you can push them or how how
good they can get what happens if you
take this architecture and you give it a
bigger data set than any of them has
ever been given and more compute to
train with you know a larger model with
more parameters and more data how good
can these things get how how good a
language model can you actually make and
that's what opening I was doing with GPT
2 so an executable binary the net effect
of slotting that T diagram against here
slightly downwards is to show you that
the C you've written gets converted into
binary and the net output from this
process it produces out a program that
you probably store in a